how you doing man I have to pay lower
please don't pull you over here
everywhere you're driving all you're
driving left lane right lane center lane
what's going on my lights I couldn't see
okay where are you coming back from I'm
coming from Rogers Rogers house
you have ID vice versa
I don't know my person
how much you have to drink tonight I've
been drinking tonight I just came back
from skipping in Rogers I see the
bourbon sales are there so oh
God too far I got plans get off the side
of this highway come on come on go ahead
and step out for me okay we're gonna get
out of the south side of the highway
just for my safety no you're sure
okay go ahead and step back there for me
okay
I just came from a Thanksgiving Rogers
I'm a student at the University of
Arkansas so I'm first Thanksgiving at my
parents house I was in lodges by the
lake and me and my mom got kind of an
argument so I've been crying like the
last 30 minutes I've just been upset but
you can check my car
okay come on step back here for me okay
uh I'm just gonna bring you through
sfsds okay
you're here oh sorry
stop leaning forward
I'm just I've been like really I just
started anxiety medicine you can see
it's in my car it's prescribed to me
it's just been making me feel really
the thing is I smell the alcohol
I can call my mom like I just I'm gonna
put you through this test
okay I'm ready okay okay you ready okay
I gotta I gotta wait for him to turn my
lights off
we'll take one two three four five
[Music]
okay
six inches yep
one thousand three one thousand four one
thousand five one thousand six one
thousand seven one thousand what and by
your side one thousand nine one thousand
two One Thousand Eleven one thousand
twelve oh I'm sorry keep going keep
going one thousand thirteen one thousand
fourteen one thousand fifteen one
thousand sixteen one thousand Seventeen
one thousand eighteen one thousand
nineteen one thousand twenty one
thousand twenty one all right stop all
right I'm gonna do uh I'm sorry hello
the worst thing we can do is over the
worst thing we do is Overlook the fact
that you're driving like crap and yeah
listen listen to it listen yeah vocal
containers got some medicine so we if
you are intoxicated we put you back on
the road we'll understand that's why
we're investigating I know and I've
already okay so what I need you to do I
need you to take a deep breath of bonus
as hard you can okay okay
deep breath a little hard
actually blow
are you blocking him to the straw with
your tongue I don't know sir
thank you I'm just really nervous okay
okay let's try this game and understand
that the truth is always going to work
out better for you in my opinion
how much have you honestly had to drink
tonight
I'm not I've moved
you know what the legal limit is
superb
so the legal limit is 0.08 if you're a
408 or higher you're beyond that legal
limit and you're driving to the top
state that right there gives us a round
of ballpark of where you're at right now
that right there says that you're at a
0.10
which means you've had far more than two
shots at two o'clock
okay
you can maintain that story but
understand the investigation's not done
now okay
we'll get you back on the road with that
okay all right so right now you're going
to be placing it on the rest okay
[Music]
all right
here's the thing you may not like this
but it's better than the alternative
that you drive down the road and you get
yourself killed or you kill somebody and
their daughter
all right
let me come over and sit over here
[Music]
take a deep breath and put it on there
blow harder harder there you go keep
going harder harder
okay I need a little bit harder okay do
you think you can do it harder I'm
trying yeah
I'll try harder yeah I need to blow a
little bit harder than that okay okay
go have a seat for me
I'm gonna take a deep breath
get into it hard a little hard take it
harder there you go there you go
almost had it
it's almost across
I don't want to do it wrong again come
on
I think I think she can just go okay
wow okay
I mean
see if you can calm yourself down okay
that's the whole thing
I know so when you're when you're
blowing and then like you're crying when
it even has a split second that you're
like
trying to catch that that catches that
that little Split Second
so so I know you're not actively trying
to do this so I'll give you one more
chance
okay so y'all need you to focus on
calming yourself down
foreign
almost had it
there you go
good job
right but just like that
put it down
yeah there's some Keepers let me see
yeah I'll let you in
you might have a
make sure he doesn't have backup
I thought
thank you
you got another keeper right here
pulling forward
pulling forward so you can keep oh
you're trying to get that
let's check for uh
foreign
okay he's good I got his belt
where's this Duty arm
we got it okay
got it yeah
we got a bus coming
okay
I can't feel anything
I got him
yeah if it's something that uh will come
off once we start moving oh we're good
okay it's all off all right we're ready
to move
the belt is still stuck on the velcro
the back just pulled it off
how you doing I'm Deputy Collins of the
Pasco Sheriff's Office is everything
okay yeah
yeah you're kind of all over the road
and when I make a U-turn you get right
up on my butt and almost rear end me no
I didn't I was upcoming you
you were not mad I made a u-turn and you
were behind me I was in the median
doing some tracking traffic enforcement
I turn around and I see you just hauling
up behind me you almost hit me in the
rear end
so do you just have your license
registration Group Insurance yeah
yeah okay where you coming from I'm
okay where's your front sauce at she
lives in Odessa oh okay what are you
heading to my home oh okay where do you
live at I live in New Port Richey
Carlton Arms oh okay
do you have anything to drink tonight no
so I'm sitting in the medium and waiting
for her to come to me and I see dispatch
shows a status updated gone in 54. so
I'm making a U-turn to get back around
and bro she's hauling obviously they
don't have moving radar but
visually estimated her she's probably
going 73 miles an hour at least and then
almost re-reends me I literally had to
haul ass and then turn on my rear lights
and then she almost drove off of the
road when I did that so I turned the
lights off after that after I alerted
her wash her patterns is all over the
road
um she reeks she says she didn't have
anything to drink but she came from her
friend's house that's why she didn't
have anything to drink
she said she's coming from her friend's
house in Odessa when this call came in
at Oakstead and 54. and then uh she's
heading home to call her arms she's
heading the right direction but she's
not coming from under that stuff
hi Miss Lindsay so here's the deal okay
so just based off how you're driving
you're concerning me and I reason
believe that you may be impaired okay
well that being said I want to do some
exercises to see if you're okay to drive
he wanted to do that for me yeah okay so
you want to do some exercises it's
really you're okay to drive yeah all
right you can just turn the car off for
me
and we're just gonna go right here in
front of your car okay you have no
weapons on your right no okay
and I'm very sorry I'm just trying to
control my GPS I understand so we can go
right here to the front of your car if
you'd like clean scoring over here
all right thank you
one two three four
[Applause]
chocolate
seven three
nine
one turning
one
two three four five
all right
four one thousand five one thousand six
seven eight thousand five
eleven
Thirty four eleven
twelve one thousand
13 14
2016 to 187 two more thousand between
two numbers
okay you can stop you can relax
you can stop you're good
just make sure you close your eyes you
have to close your eyes
place your hands on your back
you can relax you don't have to count
anymore
let's just go out this time and place
interested driving into the influence
okay
so guys right now you want to provide me
a little awful sample of your breath
and or urine
you are not okay I'll walk you back here
to my car
take a seat back is there a new way I
can put the handcuffs in front of me
because I have our arthritic outlet
syndrome so my arteries get cut off very
easily they're trying to heat itself
all over your mouth open your mouth
open your mouth flip your tongue for me
questions
sorry about that
and then in the back of the Cup Course
I'm gonna read your rides okay
I'm here with
your dad are you
hello hi there
what's going on I'm here with the cop
right now like
both him and I and I'm getting arrested
and getting taken to the Sheriff's
Office
so
you just let me answer the phone to let
you know that that's what happening
I'm sorry
but that's what's happening where are
you going
all right this is Debbie Collins
Sheriff's Office this one's gonna be
going to the land of lakes detention
center and I tell them for a while so
she's interested for driving Under the
Influence
um should be transported to the Pasco
County Jail Atlanta Lakes Florida
um
unless you we booked in and I don't
think Miss Lindsay has any Briars at all
so should we release center owner
cognizance after eight and a half hours
from the time of arrest which was about
minutes uh
I'm sorry I can't math right now so if I
shift eight hours from now so it's it's
what would that be like 12.
yeah
with me and you know
a situations but her vehicle will have
to get impounded by our policies and
affordable
um
so I can see they're going to be steps
towing or crocoding I'm not sure if you
guys are local if you guys are Michigan
so then yeah if you want I can give you
the address for the jail
but like I said they'll be like she
won't be held on bond or anything like
that it's just mandated that she sits
for eight and a half hours rest so the
time I put our handcuffs
so
I can right down
I'm sorry you guys had a call a few
times we've been a little busy and I
just want to make sure she called you
back let you know she is okay
[Applause]
there's only tell you something okay
DUIs are very recoverable
now when you start stacking up DUIs not
so much like I told you from the get-go
even very cooperative
you're not disrespectful you're not a
bad person all that happened tonight was
a mistake
and that's what I'll tell you and I'm
not trying to be yes here or anything
you made a mistake and that's what it
comes up to I think you're a nice person
you've been very respectful
and a mistake was made that's all it was
tonight right
I can tell you you're not you're not
gonna fire you over this
so long as you provide your lawful
sample of your breath
it'll still be eligible to drive in the
state of Florida
and you'll be eligible you know for a
permit and stuff like that to be able to
drive so no you're not I I doubt it'll
fire you
and plus this is a charge this is a
conviction so you're innocent until
proven guilty
foreign
we'll start
[Applause]
here
[Music]
available
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
130 130.
control
vehicles
[Music]
are you hurt
you're hurt
that one's kind of locked too hard I'll
give you a cupcake
you're good bro yeah all right
thank you for stopping okay all right
you all right man no injuries or
anything
hi Daisy
on Deputy Miller
so tell me what's going on
so I got a flat tire and I called my
sister because I know she lives close by
okay
and then a deputy walked to my car
and started asking me a bunch of
questions and I told him that I called
my sister because she lives close by did
you tell the deputy that she lived here
I told Mason
close I live in Bradenton River so I
told her she told me
to pull into the culture
like
intersection nearby where she could pick
me up
are you coming from work I am coming and
where do you work at
it and which one the one over there at
Tamiami okay all right how much you get
to drink tonight
I had much drink I had one shot whenever
so okay
I asked you one time already now that
we're out okay by refusing to perform
field sobriety exercises I have to make
a decision on whether or not I'm gonna
place you under arrest for DUI all right
so I'm gonna ask you one more time based
on my observations based on everything
okay glassy watery eyes just slow and
slow slow and slow slow and slow and
thick tongue skin okay you have an order
of alcohol beverage you're trying to
mask it with gum in your mouth okay you
have an orbital sway as I'm talking to
you you hit the curb you have two flat
tires all right all these are indicators
of impairment so I'm gonna ask one more
time are are you willing to perform
field sobriety exercise if you refuse
okay I have to make a decision on
whether or not I'll place you under
arrest for DUI
so will you perform field sobriety
exercise to spell my fear of impairment
no
all right turn around for me
turn around for me we are not playing
this turn around now and place your
hands on your back
please change on your back there you go
all right we just had a deputy killed
okay from a drunk driver
less than a week
does not did you not hear about that
you're impaired
yeah foreign
when we get down to the jail okay I have
an intoxalizer are you going to provide
your breath sample determining spread
alcohol content
yes or no
okay I'm going to read you something
5712 I got one white female 10 15 second
one
what's wrong is we have all these things
you know sisters Ubers lifts everyone
who can drive our vehicle when we drink
unfortunately you didn't want to take
any other different decision except that
you're going to drive home
I was
quite ahead
I'm now reading what's called implied
consent I am now requesting you submit
to a lawful test of your breath for the
purpose of determinants alcohol content
will you take the test yes or no
is that a no you're shaking your head to
the side no okay I need I need you to
verbalize for me please
if you refuse to take the test I have
requested of you your driving privilege
will be suspended for a period of one
year for a first refusal or 18 months if
your driving privilege has been
previously suspended or if you have been
previously fined under statute
327.35215 for a refusing to submit to a
lawful test of your breath urine of
blood additionally if you refuse to take
the test I requested of you and if your
driving privilege has been previously
suspended or if you have been previously
fined under statute
327.35215 for a refusal to submit to a
lawful test of your breath urinal blood
excuse me you will become a misdemeanor
in addition to any other penalties which
can be imposed by law a refusal to
submit to the test I have requested is
admissible into evidence in any criminal
proceeding do you understand what I have
just read to you
do you still refuse to submit to this
test
chewing gum ever since I has nothing to
do with chewing gum
yes it does it does because I literally
have do you know the law for for how
breath tests work so what happens is I'm
going to have you I'm gonna have the
whole percentage in gum time at all I'm
half um well what's gonna happen is when
we get down okay I'm gonna have you spit
out the gum and then I have to wait 20
minutes
fine but here's the thing I still I
don't have the intock size in the back
of my patrol car okay like I said when
we get down to the jail I'm gonna check
your mouth make sure you don't have
anything in there which would be the gum
I would have you spit it out I would
start 20 minute observation period of
time make sure you don't have anything
you know put anything else inside your
mouth or regurgitate after that once the
20 minutes are over then I conduct the
breath test okay that's how it works yes
it would throw it off right now because
you have something in your mouth okay
but I'm not doing it right now I'm
asking you when we get down to the jail
so I'm gonna ask again do you still
refuse to submit to this test yes or no
yes okay
well your license is going to be
suspended for a year okay
so this was found in your door do you
want to talk to me and explain what this
is or no
it's entirely your choice I can't force
you to talk to me I don't know
I don't know if it's cocaine or meth
uh my mirandizer and she didn't see
anything she's like I got bad people in
my life and I told you I told her I was
like well you can cut people out of your
life you know oh you you definitely hit
an object or you hit a curb
okay
curb or an object another vehicle or
Pole or something okay
I know for a fact you hit a curb that's
for sure because the sidewall got busted
on your tires
now if you hit something else I'm not
sure because you got front right
Corner damage
well we don't we don't tell your job or
anything like that okay
trust me I'm well aware of that I used
to pay that
I am well aware of rent by by myself it
sucks
now I got a mortgage
yeah where are you
saying where
are you able to step out with me
[Music]
you okay let's just step towards the
back of the car okay
there you go
where where are you coming from
ah need a ride home man no you 'll be
right oh
okay I don't understand what you're
saying
you're trying to get a ride home
no say it again for me I need a ride
home
so what the ride home the ride home yeah
okay where are you coming from just ride
home is that the name no yeah the ride
home like where is this this winter
garden Ride Along okay where are you
headed to my house okay where's your
house right here okay got you give your
ID on you yeah for sure if you don't
have it on you it's okay you can just uh
we'll get your name date of birth
well I mean
all right
Chase just stay on the truck for right
now okay all right
hey Chase if you want to leave that in
the seat then can we step over in this
uh this parking lot over here so we can
get you out of the roadway yeah okay if
you actually leave the keys man
um and I'll explain everything okay
okay so the reason why we pulled the
other car well first of all we found you
asleep at the light you know how long
you've been there nope okay a minute
okay have you been drinking tonight at
all
a little bit okay
um so right now the concern is uh for
your ability to drive
so I'm just going to ask you would you
be willing to answer some questions
would you willing to do some Safari
exercises for us tonight absolutely not
okay is your ID in the car yeah okay no
problem just uh if you're only on this
officer's car I'll come right back to
you then okay Chase
all right so generally what we do is we
run you through some medical questions
we do the extra the field Squad
exercises if you don't want to do those
you don't have to
um but right now you're asking us to
base our decision on your ability to
drive on what we've seen so far and what
we've seen so far is you sleep in the
vehicle you reek of alcohol
it's obviously been drinking you told us
that you came from the bar so I just
want to present you the opportunity
again would you like to do field Sprite
exercises
back
it's that easy how easy that easy let me
see your license
I'm confused what's going on here
just got here about an hour ago
[Music]
why am I why am I being like all over or
whatever I already explained to you
you're driving behind cars slamming on
your brakes driving carelessly and
screeching your tires the whole time so
you almost ran into a few cars I love
what you're running go back and forth on
the Wall Street I think that's me I'm
trying to find myself
ma'am it was clearly you because I have
two eyes that I can see with okay
perfect yeah as well and so you've been
driving back and forth to Wall Street
for like last 15 minutes or so yes I I
don't think that's me okay well we're
not arguing here
[Music]
no what about you we have you stop I
understand I got him okay our focus is
you right now when we're done with you
we'll address the others what do you
mean screeching my tires means you're
slamming on the brakes
and sliding because your your brakes are
locking up your tires are screeching on
the on a pavement
[Applause]
I really do believe you guys have the
wrong person nope
why do you say that because four eyes
cannot make the same mistake I saw you
he saw you
okay I realize I look like any other
blonde on this side all right oh
yeah yeah there's a whole bunch of that
look exactly like you're driving around
recklessly
yeah a lot I don't understand
okay we just explain that to you once
again you were following a pickup truck
on the wall real close you were breaking
and accelerating and breaking and
accelerated you made your way through
here earlier behind an electric car and
I told you to slow down
and then you came around again it
because you because listen I'm talking
now
it's not a toy it's a motivator do you
can you please keep going all right this
is not a toy this is a motor vehicle you
treating it as a toy
[Applause]
all right we got two officers that saw
you driving recklessly that's enough
probable cause to stop you now do you
need more money
sorry we're doing an investigation
here all right do me a favor come over
here
come over here thank you this is a
traffic stop Yes you gotta let us finish
our investigation
let me finish a lot more this is an
investigation all right
this is a traffic stop it's an
investigation ask you if you understand
we if she says yes all right listen to
me listen to me you cannot obstruct our
investigation she's an adult she's over
18 isn't she
so I love you all right let us finish
our investigation
where do you where are you staying what
where are you staying what do you have
stayed in a hotel or you're staying at
uh where you're staying at I'm staying
with a friend okay I'm gonna tell you
something right now if we're gonna see
you again on the scooter doing what you
were doing earlier you're going to go to
jail you understand what careless
driving I will stand with careless
driving yes yes why are you playing
stupid are you like do you have like
issue with memory or something I'm just
trying to figure out how old are you 22.
22 years old so you're an adult right
yes correct so you telling two police
officers that witness to drive like a
you know care in a careless manner you
telling us that it wasn't you is that
not the thing that wasn't me you said it
wasn't you seeing what is going on here
well I'm explaining you as an adult to
an adult okay okay so so you were
driving I know what you look like I can
see your tattoos and I know what you
know what you're driving this rental
scooter from this company you went up
and down Duval Street numerous times
what scooter number in my driving it
doesn't matter it's a rental scooter it
doesn't matter what number I'm here with
34. okay well we're just gonna give you
a ticket that's fine okay give me a
ticket
[Applause]
okay okay you're you're clearly not
comprehending or understanding
put your kickstand on your scooter
please and get off
with me
either you can walk with me normal or I
can put you in handcuffs so we can walk
over there it's just like an okay thing
am I being arrested I don't know yet
we're gonna have to go we're gonna have
a conversation about it come with me no
we need to have it by my car
you've been driving like a clown for the
past half hour this officer's watched
you once go by and then he pulled you
over the second time you've gone by
because you're driving erratically down
the street of Duval okay which is a
Saturday night which is 100 people on
Duval and you're driving like a fool so
what do my friends have to do with any
of this
okay you don't have to call them I'm
just trying to help you out but if you
don't want to call your friend that's
fine how is that going to help me how
wouldn't it help you how would it not
because you're by yourself okay
okay all right so here's the deal
you ever been read your rice before
I work for a lawyer perfect you've been
Reggie Miranda rights before I don't
care who you work for yeah sure having
these rights in mind you wish to speak
to me what happened tonight what do you
want to ask
what do you want to ask perfect where
are you coming from where is where was
your scooter parked before you got here
okay all right so here's the deal in
order to dispel my belief that you're
operating a motor vehicle in the State
of Florida on Duval Street would you
waste your submit to a field sobriety
field to body test exercises
no you do not wish to do that okay
perfect go and turn around for him put
your hands behind your back
[Applause]
[Music]
you're being you're being arrested for
the suspension of a DUI 79 minutes
perfect congratulations
[Applause]
you want to tackle me I don't want to
tackle you
clean up against the car they're gonna
come see you
in your mouth stick your tongue out lift
up your tongue for me perfect
those
are you say your name Cheyenne Cheyenne
Cheyenne Cheyenne
Cheyenne Cheyenne okay okay my third leg
where are you from originally Columbia
South America really
yes
can I go to the bathroom
no he's not no he's not
I have two step kids they are um
they're great
everyone would think that I'm like the
whitest girl ever so naturally I want so
I dyed my hair being from
school yeah yeah exactly stops being
recorded do you have your license
registration proof insurance
so do you know why I'm stopping tonight
no no so that intersection that you came
through yeah right you stopped right in
the middle of the intersection what was
the stop sign in the middle right you
almost I had to stop because I thought
you were gonna go through it
and then you went right through it right
in front of me right when I had the
right away
I just thought you were stopped there
like looking at the garage
no okay
all right so do you have the insurance
so how much alcohol you had tonight Kate
um I didn't drink tonight none
whatsoever okay so what's that odor I'm
smelling
do you have alcohol in the car you do
have alcohol okay
and I'm just driving her home okay how
is she
um she's 22. she's my roommate okay
let me check your eyes real quick keep
your head straight look at my finger
only okay with your eyes do you
understand just follow with my top my
finger with your eyes only do you
understand
okay
[Music]
all right so when's the last time you
had alcohol
um about two hours ago two hours ago
what'd you have
a white cloth a white cloth okay is that
it yeah okay all right give me a sec
I'll be right back out with you hey Kate
how about we'll talk you
all right let's just go humidity to
having alcohol okay you're under 21
years of age right yeah okay so and I
saw some Clues okay I'd like to go
through some volunteers tests with you
make sure you're okay to drive okay I
just don't want you getting hurt okay
that's my big thing I care about people
right okay all right so I'm gonna have
you do a stand on the sidewalk okay so
for this first test what I'm gonna have
you do is sandwich feet together arms
down your side like in the military I
want you to remain in that position I
might give you the instructions for this
test okay
just don't move your head okay
gonna go up
code for about testing
I'm sorry my ankle does hurt very badly
okay
[Music]
let's go
all right all right deep breath in
flow
go go go go go go go go go go
shop
all right so do you know what the legal
limit for somebody who's under 21 is I
don't so it's .02 okay so you're a point
one okay you are over that legal limit
for a regular DUI too okay so you are
under arrest for DUI at this time okay
oh okay
it's wrong never even fall six PBT point
one zero zero
[Music]
there wasn't marijuana pipe yeah okay
I'm not able to hold my phone no you
were in custody right now
I did just sprained my ankle it's okay I
believe you yeah what are you going to
school for
eign
I don't really want to sign any of these
things when I don't like understand what
that means
so you can read it yourself or I can
read it again
so then what if I'm if I have the right
to an attorney then I can call you an
attorney is that what you want an
attorney like if you want
it's up to you I've never been in a
situation like this right and so I can't
provide you any legal advice because I'm
a police officer I'm trying to do my job
okay so it sounds like you want to talk
to an attorney
which is completely fine it won't make
me mad okay it's it's all right it's
your sins as a citizen okay so what I'm
gonna do
is
pushing contact with an attorney okay
does that sound right that's not fair
all right let's go sit in that room
right there okay
I'm gonna get one on the phone
it works it's your right and it's my job
to respect that okay
thank you
all right I have a lady who's under
arrest for DUI she would like to speak
to you
can I hand her the phone
okay it's it's Roger Sandberg
asking for your signature
okay
marijuana
you did have a marijuana pipe in the
driver's door
I do smoke but I did not tonight not
tonight okay
you understand you're not supposed to
have that
so when we get to a point you may want
to fix that later okay
so no more driving with that stuff okay
same thing with alcohol yeah yeah okay
okay have you had any alcohol to drink
since being stopped so I didn't have I
given you any uncles all right good
because I would have been fired off of
that question
have you been drinking alcoholic
beverages
one drink you're sticking to it all
right what have you been drinking
white color you're sticking a white claw
and ain't no laws right
all right how much
I told you I don't make up these
questions
all right when'd you start
okay
all right who have you been drinking
with
friends friends
I actually had somebody start listing
off people like hey don't be a snitch
now
all right
where were you drinking just a house
yeah
yeah time of last drink ten
yeah all right do you believe your
ability to drive was affected by your
alcohol and or drug usage
got it
have you ever been arrested for DUI
before
I'm gonna do a criminal history track
and if you have never been arrested for
DUI you'd have the ability to bail out
tonight and call a friend to pick you up
okay and it's usually about 500 if that
what you're telling me is true and
you've never been arrested for DUI so
I don't like make promises but
you know sometimes people tell me that
they've never been arrested UI and they
have
huh yes of course so
right here
those are yours do you have pockets or
no
yeah fold those up stick those in your
pockets there's a restroom right here
with the toilet
and I will shut the door behind you
[Music]
we can call you I don't know how it
works
yeah we'll call on the wedges y'all
so I'm gonna shut the door behind you
okay so it's going back in handcuffs so
fold that stuff up put it in your pocket
so if I put your handcuffs in the front
you can act out
you don't have to worry about you trying
to fight me or anything okay sounds good
so I'll put them in front make it easy
for you okay
really small wrist
already
yeah the lock oh what's the lock
oh you just poke something on the
handcuffs yeah so that is to keep them
from getting tighter so they don't cut
off circulation to your wrist
that's great yeah no worries
can we drive to somewhere else yes we're
going to Colfax
Colfax yep
that little speed trap town
hey you better need to spend the night
in jail or
um it was 500 so
do you want the information for the jail
yes or they could possibly do a phone
sale I'm not sure about that one but I
can provide you the phone number and you
can call them and ask them if you want
to
foreign
[Music]
thank you